don't try to monetize your compassion
it's a joke you might suck at your
passion monetize what you're great at
Naturally you need to mix what you love
with what there's a demand for okay if
you love it but there's no demand you
have a hobby and that can fill your soul
but it's a hobby if you're just chasing
what's hot but you have no interest in
it you're never gonna win because you're
going up against people who absolutely
love the thing it's in that intersection
of what you love doing with what there's
a market for what about all the things
that are really difficult to love guy
sells toilet bowls for a living people
sell faucets Hardware steel how do you
love steel or is that's not the actual
business itself is it passionate about
manufacturing or passion about building
an organization it's got to be a passion
for the process if you're we're doing
this on a Monday right if you're waking
up on a Monday like oh you're done you
got to be excited about the work that
you're about to go off and do and from
all the people that I've studied that's
that's the number one trade love of the
process of what they're doing every day
need motivation watch it's out ten with
believe Nation hey seven Carmichael and
I make these videos because run into
business is hard and waking up every day
and getting to work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
from me and my team's take on my top 10
rules of success
enjoy
rule number two is get strategic how did
you grow your channel to millions of
subscribers so how I did it may not be
the best way for how you can do it right
now uh early on YouTube I started in
2009 it was a completely different game
than it is now where education was not
the main thing I made a six minute video
and people told me it was too long and I
was crazy and nobody would watch a six
minute video now YouTube is the number
one place people go to to learn the best
teachers are on YouTube you know they're
not in schools they're on YouTube so I
would start with you with well what's
the main thing that you actually want to
sell I mean I'm looking to help Real
Estate Investors buy their first
property there's three main shows that
you can launch the first show is what
most people think about which is the
thought leadership show you're making
your eight ways to launch your real
estate career or whatever eight ways to
pick properties eight ways to blank
right that means you're a good speaker
it doesn't mean that you're actually a
good coach or know how to actually help
somebody show number two is you coach
people so you have either ideal clients
or people getting their start in in the
business and you come on and you coach
them and that's a lot easier of a show
to make because you just have to show up
it assumes you're a good coach right
talking to a camera by yourself in the
studio is the hardest thing to do at the
beginning when you're actually helping
somebody it's a lot easier and then the
third show which is the fastest way to
make Revenue money is a Biz Dev show so
you think of who are the people who
generate leads for you like who are the
referral sources for you other investors
other lenders Bankers property managers
stuff like that so anybody who refers
business to you you start a show and
have those people and then those kinds
of people on your show talking about
real estate investing and those kinds of
people on your show talking about real
estate investing where the goal isn't
even to get a million views on the video
it's to build the relationships because
if a hundred different people inside of
the investing World knew who you were
who were all dealing with your ideal
clients now you've built the seven eight
figure business just off of those
relationships rule number three is learn
to monetize so this is where a lot of
people get stuck right at the beginning
I love these people and they're so good
like you didn't want to help and then
you get you get pulled into either
helping them for free or doing it like
super discounted rate yeah and you feel
so fulfilling but it's like you are not
making money right so it's it's just an
order of sequencing so it's not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money
so that we can afford to quit our job
and then make more money so we can
afford to hire a team to help us build
our brain so it like on purpose first
yes and you have to learn how to
monetize right right number one is
Mission purpose and then somewhere in
two to five has to be making money if
you're an entrepreneur or you don't make
money right so that becomes now the
opportunities okay how do we take what
you do and be able to monetize it so why
I'm asking how can you connect it to
your current work is because the more we
can we can win off of just your magic
which is great which is like believe in
the gifts and then believe in the magic
and people will feel different being
around you and want to sign up on the
spot which is great and the more we can
lean in on any kind of credibility or
history or success stories or like
that's a hard part of the beginning of a
coaching journey is because
you know if you're not doing it full
time yet and that's right it doesn't
connect to the job or work experience
you've had it's it's like it uh creates
uh resistance to want to hire you
especially at higher rates yeah so
that's what we're trying to find is like
inside of inside of your story how can
we pull out some elements that give you
more credibility so that when you're
talking to people uh they'll just want
to hire you on top of the magic rule
number four is focus on who you serve
how are you able to overcome those
barriers that were kind of those
limiting beliefs that are maybe holding
you back from becoming the thought
leader inspirational person that you
wanted to be that you are now the
starting point for me really was I
always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't most of the time
we're focused on who we're not yet well
why don't I have I've got what three and
a half million subscribers now why isn't
it five or like 50 or 100 or a billion
you know it's like it's always who are
we not and so at the beginning we really
struggle to get going because 25 people
watched your video and you feel like a
total especially if you've had success
in a different field if you had all the
success in real estate investing and
then you make a YouTube video and 25
people watch it it's like that's rough
yeah it feels like you've already tasted
success it's really hard to start at the
beginning of something new we feel like
I've got information I've got good no I
should I should be doing better than
this I just always Focus though on who I
was serving and who I wasn't when I
started on YouTube
I'd already sold my company I already
had my first exit I was already in the
Venture Capital game as well so we
already had some success I was just
doing it to try to give back and serve
and help and so if 25 people saw the
video like hey that's 25 people who saw
the video that's 25 people for one
person I might be a life-changing video
and I just always focused on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't and and
it grew to the point where they started
recommending and referring and I
understood the algorithm a little bit
better and YouTube caught up to being an
educational platform
um but if you can focus on that that hey
I did 25 today and I did 28 tomorrow and
I did 35 the next day it's like this the
growth curve starts to take off for you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is pay attention
to data YouTube is a long form platform
this podcast however long it goes well
it's not a it's not a 40 second clip
right I love data I love making data
driven decisions it might be great to
feel a certain way but I want to see
that it actually has a result 100 right
so I wanted the conversation great
YouTube YouTube gives you the best data
of any platform so when this video comes
out you'll see in your audience
retention does it there's a curve called
the audience retention curve
where basically you see where people are
leaving the video so at the start is 100
everybody who watches at zero zero zero
zero they're they're there but then as
the video goes on it says curve
you'll see at some points a sharp curve
where it drops a lot people left
whatever you did there sucked don't do
that again probably a commercial delete
my commercials gotta pay the bills guys
you know but even timing around the
commercials right if you do it too soon
you might lose a big percentage of your
audience but there'll also be these
magical moments where it's flat which
means nobody left for this two minute
clip nobody left whatever we were
talking about nobody left and then
you'll have some really magical moments
where it goes up how is that possible
people rewinding the clip to watch that
part again
that's what you cut and put your
Instagram rule number six is don't care
what others think people are so scared
of the opinions or like I said they feel
neat they feel they need to be somebody
and it's so powerful to where you know
they aren't open about it and it's it's
when you're open about it that things
start to open up for you so kind of like
when did you realize that dude many
times and I'm still going through it
just on bigger levels I'm an introvert
so that doesn't come across in my videos
and interviews like this and stuff but
but I'm an introvert so I have no need
to share my story to talk the biggest
fight I get into with my agent who's is
you know tough New York guy is Evan your
problem is you don't want to be famous
like yeah I don't I don't have a need to
be fair you need to get famous for your
message to get heard so how does an
introvert become famous I don't know I'm
trying to figure it out join me on this
journey and we'll see
um Lots man Lots uh from from big things
to little things let's start with a
little one
um I'm at I'm at Tony Robbins event so
Tony I've been working with Tony for the
past
40 fourish years
he invites me to his event to sit in his
specific chairman you know seating and
meet him backstage and all this stuff
they have these security guards who are
all around the stage because you can't
get you know somebody jumps on the stage
they have to be there yes they're
rotating right and so as they rotate
around every 20 minutes or so they do a
rotate and and the guy from that corner
comes to the front of the stage and they
they do this little fist bump with each
other
and then and then they rotate onto the
next one so they keep going in this
clockwise Direction every 20 minutes
doing fist bumps so I'm sitting there
and it's like it's happening right in
front of me because I'm in the front row
and uh I think I'm gonna fist bump the
next security guard I'm going to fist
bump I want to fist bump the next cutie
because just to show some love to
security guards you know like hey you're
important I recognize you so the next
rotation comes around my heart's beaten
so so they come and I put my fist out
like this he looks at it and keeps
walking like I just got I just got on I
just got rejected by by the security
guard at Tony Robbins a friend I can't
believe it my initial instinct is oh my
God I hope nobody like who saw that did
anybody see me just get destroyed in
here by the security guard and of course
we always make the story way bigger in
our head than it is like yeah chances
are almost nobody saw it and the ones
who did that they even care and I'm sure
like two people maybe saw it and they're
laughing great but in my head it's like
everybody the whole world's hot right
um and so
in that 20 minutes before the next
security guard fist bump came up I'm
sitting there I'm reflecting I'm not
even listening to Tony at this point
because I'm I'm stuck in my world about
the Lost response like what do I do next
and and here's the thing that got me to
do the fist bump again
humans are built to serve
humans are built to serve we're wired to
serve like serving and helping others
does the same thing to your brain as
food and sex like we're wired to serve
yep it's human nature it's human nature
human nature yeah and at the same time
we are
afraid of of other people's opinions
judgments expectations and so most
people live life with their their foot
on the gas and the break at the same
time because serving involves other
people you have to help others you have
to do something for others it's not just
serving yourself that doesn't feel good
it's serving other people but if you're
also at the same time afraid of how
they're going to react and judge you
then you never do anything rule number
seven is find your Market we have a big
mission to change the world right I mean
and it's like okay our immediate goal I
need and maybe we hit that in a couple
months doesn't have to it doesn't have
to take the December to
if you have 10 clients who are still
over happy too right very much so but
the immediate goal is it's not some
crazy thing that you're coming in to say
I need to have right a thousand clients
paying me right yeah so it's five
clients five clients between now and the
December right yeah perfect at a minimum
so then it's who are the best people who
can afford you yeah to pay two thousand
dollars a month if you're calculated
with women then we could find it's women
it's not that you only have to do one
but it's helpful to yeah narrow in on
like the right influences to take you to
the path right so
is it women in careers so I've honestly
mostly been haven't coached any woman oh
I've been coaching men okay
um and it's been the people who I have
been coaching are people that are in the
um like in the fitness space so it's
more of a figuring who are the people
who have budget who can hire you or you
get paid to
come in to an organization and help them
with their team yeah exactly honestly
like as I think more about this it's
like how can I create the Maximum Impact
right not yet
yeah yeah it doesn't make you money in
the next three years well that's true
and we need we have a drop dead date
December 31st yes yes you're right and
right yeah so but that's not the
question right now Maximum Impact we
just need impact right Maximum Impact on
like individuals but not world oh yes
high impact and we need to be paid to do
it so we can continue to build and scale
okay
I think people who are going to be
entrepreneurs is a really hard Market
because they just don't have
budget right and especially if they quit
their job and then they go to start
their business then they have no more
money to pay you yeah so the coaching
will probably end absolutely so it's
finding people who are it could be if
you're making a quarter million plus a
year and you want to start a business
yeah you know I'm good I'm I'm gonna
help you
and I would get the 25k up front
nice once things start to visit it's
going to be really hard to yeah right
and I collect after every session okay
yeah up front yeah like all of that it
could be potentially negotiable right
could I do quarterly installments could
I do just six months you don't have to
say no to it but you can say like here's
yeah here's here's what we did rule
number eight is build relationships what
advice would you give to that person
that's watching this show who's a
business owner that wants to start
content marketing posting on YouTube You
Know YouTube shorts Instagram stuff like
that I would again look at the first the
three shows that I talked about at the
beginning most people when they're
looking at creating content they do the
thought leadership show which is the
most awkward show for people to do
because they struggle to talk into a
camera for most businesses your business
is professional speaking then okay
that's a huge Advantage for you but for
most people they're not trained in how
to speak in front of a camera and so
they start making content and they suck
and it's true like you do suck but
doesn't mean you suck as a person it's
just a skill set that you have to
develop to continue to work on I usually
end on the first show which is the biz
Dev show even if this doesn't do well
who are the people that you want to
build relationships with that having
them on your show leads to referrals for
your company because every company
that's already established knows the
value of referrals now let's increase
our chance to get more referrals and
asking somebody to come on your show is
a lot easier than asking somebody to
Coffee to talk about a potential you
know partnership or referral Arrangement
right so it's about relationships rule
number nine is Embrace challenges I try
to train myself
that I do hard things
I do hard thing I love hard things what
you want easy things for the rest of
your life
do you want to just then you're inside
your comfort zone photocoping your day
over and over again yep no no growth
there yeah so so you actually love hard
things you love difficult things and so
if the examine whatever it is that you
want to do for everybody listen right
what is your goal what do you want to
accomplish what's that idea in your head
what's the reason why you're not doing
it
okay well often it's it's harder it's
difficult okay great you do hard things
awesome or I'm afraid
great you do scary things too you want
to just do things where you know the
outcome of forever
no you want it it's boring you'll hate
your life so so if you want
you want your calendar in the next month
that doesn't scare you you hate your
life that's true there's so much better
than that there's something you have to
do things that scare you whether that's
reaching out to somebody for an
interview whether that's fist bump on a
security guard where the whatever it is
like there has to be something in your
schedule consistently that scares you
that makes your heart boom boom boom
boom boom otherwise you're in your
comfort zone and you hate your life and
so what's the reason why you're not
doing the thing that you're doing it
can't be because it's hard or difficult
and it can't be because you're scared
and so try to catch that in your own
language
wow I can't do that because it's too
hard no no I do hard things so I'm I'm
triggered already when you said hard
because I taught myself so much
I do hard things I love it give me the
heart man I want the heart I only do
heart
um so that's a great if people can catch
it in their own life
um then then that's use that as that's
how you actually build self-love
self-confidence self-respect if you win
and it's easy you might post about it on
Instagram that you want but you don't
feel great because it's a fake win yeah
but if you if you get up and you just
try and it's difficult that's how you
actually build self-love self-confidence
self-respect by doing difficult things
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is never
quit you're a big believer in in belief
systems so it's almost like before you
have that first big win under your belt
it's almost like you don't think it's
possible and because that you don't take
the actions because when you play the
movie you're like I can't see myself
being successful right yeah and so I
mean I didn't need to go do something
next but I also wasn't set for life and
I was also 22. so what was the
distinction what happened that you say
you know when the what was the change
modeling success I mean I felt like I
tried everything myself nothing was
working I told my business partner that
I quit worst day of my life
um because nothing was working you know
it wasn't that we didn't agree on things
just nothing was working I need to feel
like I was a valuable human again and so
I said I quit and then you know barely
slept that night and the next day said I
can't quit I if I quit now I'm going to
regret it I just have to find another
way to stand
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not that one sentence is at
the core of how I've been able to stay
so consistent to keep making content to
not give up to not get too discouraged
and to get back up every single time and
keep going because I focus on who I am
serving instead of who I'm not
I just recently spoke at Brandon
burchard's influencer Summit and I
shared my graphic of how I've grown over
the years on my channel every time I
show that graph they always ask me how
did you keep going in in the first five
years when you had no subscribers when
you had no comments how did you keep
going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and I don't think I'm
superhuman I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story I had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles in getting my channel and just
belief in myself to put anything out
there I hated my first 350 videos I
couldn't watch anything back totally
embarrassed by everything I made
and it was 750 videos before I inspired
myself before I finally liked one of my
own videos like you know what I'm
starting to get decent at this that was
a good video 750 videos in before I did
that so how how do you keep going how
does that make any sense
because I always focus on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your girl think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you get
nothing right there's no reaction
there's no comments and then maybe you
get one comment and then maybe you get
five comments maybe you get 10 likes or
maybe you get however many views on your
videos right you got 100 views on your
video now that's kind of the standard
now if you get 20 views I got on a video
oh that that doesn't feel so good right
or if you get a thousand views on a
video or 10 000 views on if there are a
hundred thousand views on a video I
remember the first time I got a hundred
thousand views on a video it's like wow
I've made it
[Laughter]
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got ten percent of that and
you feel like oh I I suck it's not
working right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people if you want a
guaranteed way to move into action apply
the 595 rule spend five percent of your
time planning and 95 of your time doing
five percent planning 95 doing most
people are afraid to apply the 595 rule
because you're afraid that you'll take
the wrong action that you'll make a
mistake that it won't be perfect but
here's what's going to happen while you
are sitting there planning your perfect
next move someone with less Talent with
less skills than you will win with a
half-baked idea because they applied the
595 Rule and just got started and then
don't think about it just go off and do
it
stop planning that's the plan the plan
is done stop planning now do you are
where you are because of you
because of the choices you've made
because of the mindset that you have
because of the lack of accountability
you are where you are because of you and
that is a very tough message to hear but
it's also a very liberating and freeing
message to hear because it's so
comfortable and so so easy to blame
other people we just we would love to
blame other people you know we would
love it's so easy to say well I'm here
because of my parents you know or I'm
here because of the country that I was
born in or I'm stuck here because of the
president and the and the policies that
the president put into place I'm here
because of XYZ whatever story happened
to you right it's so much easier to stay
stuck in blaming other people
because it means we don't have to do
anything
because it means that it's not your
responsibility to fix it like it makes
sense this is why you're stuck right
like oh well this is why if I had this
set up for me then then of course it'd
be more successful you know if my
parents were like this and of course
it'd be more successful
it takes the accountability and the
responsibility off of your shoulders
and that's a very comforting message but
it keeps you stuck
[Music]
it keeps you staying exactly where you
are it keeps you in slow growth or no
growth mode
where when you can flip it to I'm here
because of me
and I will end up in a different spot
because of me that where I start right
now is not where I'm going to finish
that where I am right now
is not going to be where I end up
because of the actions that I'm going to
take
one important
thought that I want to get across in
this video is there is a very big
difference between taking accountability
and placing blame
what want to do is blame we want to
blame others
and we don't want to blame ourselves
I'm not asking to blame yourself blaming
doesn't do anything
blaming is still negative thinking
blaming is still
being stuck in the past
you're sitting there even blaming
yourself you're stuck in a path oh I
should have done this how many times
have you done that how many times have
you done that I should have done this I
should have been more proactive I should
have taken that chance when I had when I
had the opportunity I should have asked
that question I should have started that
business three years ago I should have I
should have I should have right you're
blaming yourself that's not what this is
taking accountability is not blaming
yourself for all your past mistakes
because if you're stuck in blaming
blaming others or blaming yourself you
stay stuck still too you're in a really
negative
mindset and you say stuck and don't do
anything that's not what this is what
this is is saying I don't want to stay
stuck here
and the difference is going to be me
taking accountability for my life
so how do we how do we start to get
there
let me share a couple pointers okay
number one
find some Heroes
chances are whoever you look up to
whoever your hero is
whether it's Oprah Winfrey Kevin O'Leary
Richard Branson Steve Jobs whoever your
hero is
your hero probably started with less
than what you have right now
less money
less support less Freedom less
opportunities
they started with less than what you
have right now
so how did they break free like how did
they get out of the situation that they
were in the the bigger hole that they
were in compared to the hole that you're
in how did they get out
because that not only gives you strategy
but also gives you the hope and
motivation to recognize well if this
person could do it from a worse
situation to what I'm in right now
the difference is they didn't stay stuck
in the blame game
they took responsibility and they got
out you can too
surround yourself with Heroes whether
that's watching YouTube videos whether
that's reading books listening to
podcasts but be around your Heroes
because they have a different mindset
most people do not take responsibility
or accountability they don't we don't
want to because it's the harder path we
want to take the easy way out so the
people you're listening to the people
who are around you the people who are in
your life right now likely are not the
ones saying I'm responsible for my life
and I'm gonna go fix it right
around you are doing the opposite to say
no I'm this this person's fault
so we have to start to shift that you
have to be around your Heroes more
so who are the people you look up to you
respect you love the most I have the
mindset that you want to have the belief
that you want to have the confidence
that you want to have who are those
people
and then surround yourself with them
more subscribe to more YouTube channels
the right YouTube channels that follow
more people on Instagram the right
people like do a real audit of the
people that you're hanging out with even
virtually
right garyvee or Elon Musk might not
come and Mentor you personally but you
can learn a lot from them from their
content from their interviews from their
books from their podcasts from their
shows you can learn a lot from them if
you choose to surround yourself with
them so do an audit of who you follow on
Instagram of who you follow on YouTube
do an audit and see how many of these
people make you feel better about
yourself give you hope ambition courage
that when you watch their stuff you
consume their stuff you're around it you
leave feeling better if you're scrolling
through Instagram and you close it and
you feel worse about yourself it's your
responsibility to fix that because
there's lots of people you could follow
who give you motivation inspiration hope
courage momentum action
YouTube as well you could die down and
watch eight hours of YouTube and then
feel terrible about yourself because you
just got distracted we're entertaining
yourself you were consumed by negative
content you can switch that unsubscribe
from all those people
and start to follow more channels that's
why I make so much content holy cow how
much content do I make every day I don't
know across all the channels there's so
much content but you know what it's
always positive it's always spreading
belief it's always healed with hope
you'll never see videos on my channel
talking about how terrible somebody is
or how we should cancel this person or
how bad the world is right and whether
you love my content great or somebody
else is awesome but most important is
the feeling you have about yourself
because when you're filled with hope
confidence courage Your Life totally
changes so step number one is you have
to be around your Heroes step number two
to starting to take responsibility is
what's the action that you can do today
you know what can you do today to start
building some momentum if you accept
that hate it's not my fault where I'm at
but it's my responsibility to fix it
right it's not your fault
it's not blame
but it's your responsibility to change
it for yourself and for others that you
can change it that you could be the one
you could be the Difference Maker where
this all starts to change
right what is that immediate momentum
you need to take do you need to launch
your own YouTube channel do you need to
start writing your book you need to
create your program you need to get on
stage and speak you need to launch that
service or product do you need to do
that collaboration like what's what's
the what's the next step
because the biggest thing that's missing
for most people is just momentum you've
got the ideas and the hard and the drive
and the and the love and the care and
the desire to do good and you want to
serve and you want to make money and you
want to build it but you want all these
things great but what's the momentum
that's happening
what's the next step
to get you out of the hole
and then number three is just scheduling
that in because no matter how bold and
confident and ambitious you feel right
now this is a process that takes time
and you can do
a lot in one day but we tend to
overestimate what we can do in in a day
and underestimate what we can do
you know in a year or in two years or in
five years
so the difference is going to be the
actual momentum that we start taking
consistently so you have one great day
today amazing what's happening tomorrow
what's happening the next day and it's
creating a calendar that you can stay
consistent on
you don't have to stay stuck
where you are in one year can be a
totally different spot than where you
are right now
the difference is not beating yourself
up not blaming yourself for the people
around you not saying how much people
screwed you over and just keep on
thinking about the negative things that
happen to you growing up
and instead saying you know what
it's my responsibility to fix this
I'm taking accountability for my life
and I refuse to be stuck in the same
spot one year from today the reason why
you're not following through is because
you're doing it alone
when you wake up and you feel like you
are by yourself you are all alone you
have no Community you're not
collaborating you're not doing this with
anybody else
it's just
massively difficult to follow through
still possible absolutely
but this is the life of an entrepreneur
this is why so many great entrepreneurs
don't follow through and it
breaks my heart because
You've Got Talent you've got a desire to
serve and the help and you know you have
a story that matters and you're just not
as consistent as you know you could be
and it's not that you suck it's just
that you're doing it alone this is
something I've struggled with
in terms of being a great resource for
people because I actually have a very
low Community need I think the journey
that I went through is
almost impossible to model
because I just woke up every day and I
still made videos and I still make
content and I did it by myself and it's
not prescriptive it's really difficult
to
do it exactly the way that I did most
people need more Community than me I
still need it
but I have a really low maybe it's just
introverted or or uh whatever but I just
don't need it as much as most people
you probably need more Community you
probably are not following through
because you feel isolated and alone and
the great promise of Entrepreneurship is
freedom right like you don't have to
have a boss you don't get to you don't
have to have employees that you hate or
people on your team who you hate you
know you get to pick everything you want
but then to go from having a job where
you have Community even if it even if
you didn't enjoy the work you were doing
which you got from the job if you've had
one is community that you had co-workers
and you had some people who you did like
and you had people to go to lunch with
and you you know you had just human
connection every day where as an
entrepreneur you don't have that
nearly as much or at all
and so it's very lonely
and it's really hard to do great work
when when you're lonely
so what's the solution
okay great yeah you just tore my heart
open Evan now what do I do how do I fix
it well first is just recognizing that
that is a problem you know first is
recognizing that there's nothing wrong
with you there's nothing wrong with you
you're amazing the only problem is you
just don't have anybody that you're
collaborating with that you're doing
this by yourself so the answer is we
need to now go and find other people to
collaborate with I think I am much more
logic driven when I look at like
evaluation so try I I have a lot of art
but I tend to make these take a bigger
decisions with logic so trying to even
though you say follow your it's a little
bit challenging for me to make that
switch it's the only thing that matters
though for this
like this is the this is the ultimate
skill to learn
for big decisions like this it doesn't
mean like the concern then becomes well
we get too emotional and then I just do
whatever comes into my head and with a
little no you're not you're never going
to be that guy you're never going to be
Reckless
yeah but for big
imagine if you're getting married
you better love her
as opposed to well logically you know
like it makes sense
I think it's probably both of those
right but it better
it better be a lot more on the love than
on the logic
um yeah like you see a lot of the guys
here have been married for a while like
oh my gosh I hope he gets this like I'm
not married yet so that's one of the
reasons like this is this isn't this is
a skill set to start to trust your heart
which you need you need both
there are some people who only listen to
the heart and are like doing all sorts
of crazy things and never say consistent
on anything and and never listen to the
hat and never stay focused never gets
that's not you you're the opposite yeah
so you need you need to tap into heart
more and it'll make you a more
successful
business person human how husband you
don't like to focus on that how do you
tap into the heart is like I guess the
last question when you feel
something come through you
when you get an idea
your next step is when you get an idea
go do something on it
yeah the two percent rule two percent
difference right so when you get an idea
what you will do is automatically start
to plan it and judge it and come up with
everyone's holding up the special
Cleveland Edition uh apparently I got
that copy as well 2019 tour let's go
yeah that's it like when you get an idea
do something on it and and the good news
is it's all low risk like what what's
your next idea but to to train yourself
that great ideas flow through you and to
take some immediate action on it this is
what I did because I'm much more logical
and strategic
I I was like you and I had to train
myself to do more heart
first
big decisions with your heart because if
you go into your next career or your
next relationship just doing logic first
you're always going to be unhappy is get
really clear on what the Habit is that
you want to develop don't pick 20
different habits that you would want to
do all at once this is where we we
struggle because we take on way too much
like okay that's it I'm done I'm rolling
up my sleeves it's time to change my
life I've had it I've had enough I'm
gonna change everything I'm gonna work
out and I'm gonna I'm gonna eat well and
I'm gonna make content I'm gonna grow my
business I'm gonna find a girlfriend I'm
gonna like whatever the thing is you
come with 20 different habits that
you're gonna do
and guess what you do it tomorrow maybe
and then and then it becomes too
overwhelming too much too much change
all at once
your life just takes over and you end up
back down in the hole where you started
does that happen if you tried to take on
too much at once what is the single most
important habit that you need to start
to build that if you look back in a year
you could say I'm so happy that I built
this one habit because it's helping you
accomplish your goals what is the most
important habit it could be waking up at
a certain time it could be taking care
of your your mind it could be taking
care of your body it could be putting in
a certain amount of work on your
business it could be right in your book
it could be making 100 videos like what
is the one habit
that you want to start to build that if
that one thing happened
your entire life starts to change
it's the Cornerstone habit that you
start doing that because they guarantee
you listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too I'm
passionate about helping I want people
to learn man and I don't think we're
getting it in schools I don't think
you're getting entrepreneurship
knowledge and textbooks and I'm
passionate about trying to help the
entrepreneurs who have the information
to get it out there so I've connected
with pretty much everybody I guess in
the thought leadership Entrepreneur
Space and I just help them with their
channels and and good stuff happened you
know I mean even looking at this I don't
know how we got initially connected but
we hopped on a call maybe a month or two
ago the look at your YouTube channel and
then you said hey man come on my show
like I'm down you know good things
happen when you give so if you're a
business owner you're an expert at
something your job is to teach people to
think like you think
and what I love you look at my letter
you look at yourself you guys think
differently right the way you approach
things you're not your typical
boardroom CEO professional corporate guy
right and so
the questions that you ask are not the
normal ones the way you see the world is
not what other people see and so that's
that's your job as a as an expert as a
business leader to share the way that
you see the world so others can see the
world the same way being good with
people has has historically been a
challenge for me being shy introverted
find it find it hard to start off
conversations but the thing that
actually helped the most
um was I should just be curious about
people
just find a way to be curious about
somebody because I think especially if
you're introvert
uh we don't like having very surface
level conversations
we don't like talking about the weather
we don't like talking but hey how about
that sports team you know it feels fake
and introverts don't like being fake
uh but we love we actually love deep
conversations and so the way to do that
is to start finding one thing that you
can be really curious about the person
if you can generally be curious about
them then it's so much easier to have a
conversation and you're asking questions
about them and people love talking about
themselves so the way to be good with
somebody is just ask some questions but
not that it's leading to a sales pitch
or something that you just genuinely
care about the person and all of a
sudden they're doing most of the talking
and then at the end of it they're saying
wow that person you're such a great
conversationalist I really like talking
with you really was them doing most of
the talking and you asking the questions
but it's got to be questions that you
genuinely are curious about and care
about I find that that really helps me I
think comparison to other people is
fantastic I think most people just do it
wrong I think most people just do it
wrong you look at somebody else you see
their life you see what they're doing
you see their business see the success
you see how old they are as one of the
common questions people ask well how old
are you well typically it's because they
want to they want to judge their own
progress against yours
the comparison can be great but you have
to use it as a kick forward instead of a
kick down most people will kick
themselves down they realize that you
haven't you realize you haven't done
much you realize that you're not where
you want to be you realize all these
other people have done it with maybe
less resources than you at an earlier
age than you and you feel like it's over
and you can't do it that's a kick down
it's a comparison it's a kick down and
that's what most people do and that's
why there's so much advice out there
from people saying don't compare
yourself to others because when we do it
we typically kick ourselves down that's
the wrong way to do it the comparison to
other people
comes from knowing what's possible and
being inspired to want to go off and do
it
you know I just came back from a trip
with my beach gang and it's
some big name people it's Brandenburg
Charlotte and Mel Robbins and uh Lewis
Howes and Jay Shetty and you know all
these all these big people who've done
big things
and we sit around the table
and we share and we help and it's our
own Mastermind it's not a paid thing
it's where they go and and we all share
and as they're talking this they're
sharing what they're up to and what
they're working towards
I'm thinking that's what's possible
that's what I could do if I wanted to
that's what that's how they're doing
their marketing okay if I could do this
and maybe they're three years ahead of
me but by learning their strategies I
can get there in six months
the comparison pushes you forward
runners run faster when there's somebody
next to them businesses innovate faster
when there's competition
comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday is not enough of a push
forward that's the problem comparing
yourself to who you were yesterday is is
a great it's great for self-love
but it's not enough of a push
so I'd encourage you to start thinking
about an audit for yourself right now
if you're really low
if there's no self-love
if you don't feel like anything is
possible that's where you look back and
you look at the progress that's when you
look back and say where was I five years
ago where was I 10 years ago look at how
much you've grown and learned and
improved and how much in a better
situation you are compared to where you
used to be even if it's not financially
just mindset just mentally just the kind
of person you are how you treat people
you've probably grown if you're watching
this channel
it means you're into personal growth
self-development
so whether it's from my videos or
somebody else's content you've been
learning and growing over the past five
years you've grown a lot you're not the
same person you used to be you're a lot
more proud of yourself than who you used
to be and whenever you're feeling low on
yourself that's when you look back and
track the progress that's when you look
back and see who you used to be and how
much you've grown and improved and
gotten better and that can
start to fill you up again
but when you're ready for growth
when you're ready for ambition when
you're ready for the next level
I think the comparison is fantastic
I think to know that something is
possible it's the whole Roger Bannister
four minute mile nobody thought it was
possible then Roger Bannister did it and
now everybody's doing it not everybody
but a lot of people did it why because
they were comparing themselves to him
because they know now that it's possible
and so when you see somebody else do it
when you see somebody else making
amazing things you don't have to default
to say I suck because they're doing it
and I'm not that's a kick down you can
choose
to use it as inspiration to say that's
what's possible
and if she can do it if he can do it
then so can I
and use that as the push to get you to
the next level
at our beach gang
last year
I got challenged a couple times I got
challenged by Brendan I got challenged
by Russell Brunson I got challenged by a
whole bunch of people and and I got
challenged without people even talking
to me sometimes just by them sharing
their story
I look at that and say I want to do that
not in the way that I suck and I can't
do it but no in a year I want to be
there in two years I want to be there in
five years I want to be there I want to
be there I want to be there I look at
young Les Brown I think he's the
greatest speaker of all time I don't
look at him and say
he's so much better than me he's got
this natural gift I suck I'm never going
to do it I look at him and I say I want
to be that good that's what's possible
it's an inspiration to move forward
so how do you make it tactical
there's a couple things that I think
would be helpful for you one
look at some people who you respect
inside your industry or outside you're
interested it's just something that you
respect about them maybe it's me maybe
it's Jordan Peterson maybe it's Oprah
who are the people that you look up to
in respect
what are the things so two what are the
things about them then that you want to
get better at if you respect somebody's
because they're they're ahead of you
it's something that you want to be good
at
maybe it's in their business maybe it's
in their speaking maybe it's in their
relationships they've done something or
they're living a way that is ahead of
you
so what is that thing too what is that
thing what is the thing that they have
that you are aspiring to get better at
there's no one person who is the ideal
Mentor you don't want to be me you don't
want to be Jordan Peterson you don't
want to be Oprah
they have parts of their eye Parts in my
life that you don't want
the whole point is to take different
pieces from different people to make the
best you you wanna for me I wanna be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs that's why
he's on my wall and I want to be a
father like my father was that's why
he's on my wall I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs was and I don't
want to be a Visionary like my dad
because they're not
so you're taking different people and
different things from them to help you
become the best you
so one is you're making a list of all
the people that you look up to that you
respect that there's something about
them that you you gravitate towards to
you find that specific thing I wanna I
Wanna Have Courage like this person I
want to have love like this person I
want to be a husband or or a wife like
this person right I want to be a mother
or father like this person that they're
the ideal to shoot towards and prove you
to make you want to strive to get better
and then three you dive into their story
you dive into their content you dive
into their videos their books their
podcasts their biographies you dive into
them on a consistent basis watching One
video is not enough it's a consistent
basis to help you start
to think like that
somebody asked me yesterday why do you
read so many books at a time I read
seven to ten books at a time I never
really thought about why I do it it just
seemed to work for me but as I dissect
it I love micro dosing on books I love
micro dosing on content because think
about what happens when you read a book
so one of the books I'm reading right
now is Jay shetty's think like a monk so
when you're reading Jay shetty's book it
it forces you to start thinking like a
mug it forces you to have more presence
and more gratitude and more mindfulness
and if you're going to read some
hardcore the other another book I'm
reading is 75 hard from Andy frizzella
which is in your face hardcore punching
you in the stomach you know yelling at
you let's go
totally different Vibes I like both
I don't want a bj Shetty I don't want to
be any Priscilla
but I like the mindfulness and present
of of Jay Shetty and I like the
aggressiveness and push of any for
selling in that combination is Evan
Carmichael
so why I read seven to ten books at a
time is because the micro dosing of the
books when you're reading a book if I
only read Jay shetty's book I've become
very mindful very very grateful very
present and then I put the book down and
they pick up a different book and then
what you start to do is lose
the train of thought you lose the thing
that you learn from Jay unless you're
picking up another Jay Shetty book but
he's only got one out right now
so instead instead of going hardcore and
just reading one book I like having Jay
Shetty once a week I like having Annie
Priscilla once a week I like in the
videos that I make to have different
people we have Jordan Peterson once a
month and Elon Musk wants a month and
Oprah once a month because diving deep
on one person can be great
but what happens on the ongoing I'm much
more concerned about the ongoing than I
am about the what's happening intense at
the moment
because the ongoing is how you win
if you want to have success in anything
going going to the gym and working out
for four hours is not going to do much
for you but if you go to the gym every
day for half an hour you'll start to see
results
a bunch of stores in there but the main
concept is I think comparison is
fantastic you just have to use it
smartly when you look at somebody else
understand that you don't want their
entire life
you don't want their entire life
but there's something about them that
they're better than you at and use that
as inspiration for you to get better
instead of you telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it
comparison will push you forward
comparison will help you get the life
that you want as long as you're kicking
yourself forward not down
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from garyvee check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there lean in dramatically
more to things that are positive your
grandfather podcasts lean into
positivity then eyes wide open and is
this delusional and lacks practicality
like you know if I just